tu sais pourquoi les illusions sont
dangereuses ce sont des jours qu'on ne
veut pas attraper cette source à 66
heures c'est le temps qui nous reste
avant la fin du monde et aux autres
[Musique]
c'est normal d'avoir peur mais je sais
que tu es capable
paul qui doit terminer la mission
[Musique]
il a eu une année incroyable michael
bryce et le garde du corps de l'année
est ce que c'est un parent à vous
certainement pas nerius kincaid est un
tueur à gages recherchés pour des
milliards de meurtre et vous faites
souvent ce rêve juste une fois
alors et par nuit d'accord vous devriez
peut-être faire une pause
[Musique]
je suis en congé sabbatique et
franchement
je sais pas pourquoi je n'y ai pas pensé
plus tôt
[Musique]
c'est comme si le monde entier attendait
que j'arrive à évoluer pour la première
fois je commence à imaginer ma vie sans
protéger celle des autres c'est vraiment
on se connaît tous la mafia a enlevé mon
mari tué les faut qu'on aille au soir il
n'est pas question que je m'applique
j'ai des consignes thérapeutiques très
strict
j'ai promis à ma psy des répliques plus
de garde rapprochée
ça veut dire pas d'arbre ou abba de
meurtre et pas de sens
qu'est ce qui faut ici lui c'est une
bombe lacrymo je suis en congé combien
de fois j'ai failli me faire tuer baas
et
on voulait avoir un bébé c'est quoi ce
manque
je serai pas une super maman franchement
c'est bien sûr un enfant serait
tellement chanceux de grandir dans ton
ventre
[Musique]
falloir tout nous raconter vous pouvais
aller vous faire
faux moi de mon côté je dirai tout ce
que je sais tout cas tu m'a fait de la
peine
allez tu viens on ne s'approche jamais
jamais de la surface
c'est clair tout est génial à la surface
tu vas voir la marche vers le ciel les
nuages le soleil
non faut pas le regarder je rigole bien
sûr qu'il faut le regarder
c'est déjà bien ouais ça rend ma
spécialité
[Musique]
sur un poêle à bois
c'est quelqu'un de la chance aujourd'hui
[Musique]
c'est tranquille
allez va créer ton club le klub des
loosers
tu m'appelles tout l'air mal cobayes
nous les rebelles on doit rester
solidaires on n'est pas des rebelles
merci à ton avis c'est pour tuer moi
c'est tout ce qu'ils nous disent
tellement plus simple
vous avez une lumière de choses qu'on
sera incapable d'accomplir
il suffisait besson
vous êtes très louche tous les deux
c'est trop dangereux
moi je connais le problème table ou non
dans la tête un bon nous dit
silencio gould au silencio blood hbo a
t-il un cube lugo sur blue ridge
longtemps encore ok toi c'est tout voilà
allez accroche toi
[Musique]
ce sera parfait pour la soirée
échangiste tu veux parler de la soirée
troc ray soirée où on échange les objets
on y songe quand même avec plaisir est
donc rentré tard à les soirées
échangistes ça traîne toujours en
longueur et soirée et ce soir ils sont
juste parce que bon le bridge scrabble
aux blues à mongongu vous fais ça depuis
quand mais ça fait des années je faisais
déjà eu mon mari lui il aimait pas il
trouvé qu'ils avaient trop dessus bon
effectivement ce serait mieux si le plus
de jeunes
ça vous dirait de venir non non non
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
hvm coup c'est cette soirée m'a cassé
les pattes
[Musique]
mendy retard
venus en grande bretagne je cherche
jacob kosminsky
est-ce que vous lui voulait c'est mon
frère
est-ce que je peux y trouver le dingue
revenir h c'est une espèce d'hôpital un
asile de fous nous avons retrouvé le
corps de mary jane kelly dans la chambre
de votre frère elle était dans son lit
frère n'est pas un artiste votre frère
est un monstre
si vous voulez garder une bonne image de
votre frère fait demi tour
on a passé deux en russie
vous aurez la chambre voisine
l'éventreur en a après vous regardez
bien voir parce que j'y suis
qu'est ce que c'est que ça
peut-être que les vendeurs me suis déjà
en permanence où tu me retrouvera au jeu
ce soir
vous voulez servir d'appât
[Musique]
vous êtes des pages blanches immaculées
y blanche immaculée vous n'aviez pas de
vocation jusqu'à maintenant jusqu'à
maintenant
félicitations vous êtes les cinq âmes
qualité soit d'hypothermie pas toucher
si l état ne répétez pas tout ce que je
dis arrêtez vous avez été sélectionné
pour faire partie d'une organisation
secrète dont la principale mission est
d'empêcher les autres de partir dit si
tu possèdes planète ridicule à terre
notre redoutable bande at elle un nom
hyper sympa oui l ona elle est connue
sous le nom de l'apocalypse
[Musique]
il a pris la barre qu'elle était là sur
le lac avec une arme j'avais même pas
connaissance et tu me craint plus rien
il a dit que j'avais raison dans sa
lettre mais par rapport à quoi
je sais pas je croyais qu'on avait aucun
secret tout le monde avait secret
[Musique]
gare un tas de femmes qui me ressemblent
toutes un peu mais pas complètement non
plus un rêve maintenant lorsque tu
trouveras ya rien qui peut aider
aujourd'hui je crois que vous avez connu
mon mari il faut que vous sachiez un
truc
qu'est-ce qu'il construisait
c'était notre maison mais inversés
[Musique]
il rêvait peur de plus pouvoir refouler
sa foulée quoi tu vas pas bien
au bout et c'est
bientôt
ah ouais
[Musique]
ça tu m'entends ça me tue en sécurité
maintenant
ou quoi tu être honorées dans le
labyrinthe
il paraît qu'il ya un profilers avec
elle maintenant profilers ils essaient
d'entrer dans sa tête
maintenant on n'a plus besoin de toi
[Musique]
bien soir tu étais dans le marais du à
vue la jeune fille a été arrêtée et a
appelé les secours la fille n'était pas
seul j'ai raison tu appelles ça manque
d'arbres été tués a été kidnappé il ya
15 ans
mon expérience m'a appris qu'il ne
fallait négliger aucune piste des lapins
le moment est sans doute venu de vous
présenter un nid
il faut qu'on sache de quoi tu te
souviens à ce jour et il faut que j'y
arrive avant lui pourquoi
[Musique]
l'histoire ne s'arrête pas là je me
trompe
[Musique]
ce n'est pas d'or il habite dans ton
esprit
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
canal+ première c'est un film 100%
inédit en salle exclusivement réservée
aux abonnés canal
je veux que vous m'aidiez à pénétrer
dans la chambre forte la plus sûre du
monde
moi je suis ingénieur pour réussir là où
tous les autres ou échouer il nous faut
un esprit supérieur
ils sont entrés la caméra n'est plus sur
toi tu à 90 secondes
en stockant superproduction pour un
casse dans la lignée de ocean's eleven
la chambre forte se trouve sous un
réservoir d'eau votre nouveau film
inédit par le réalisateur de la saga
grecque
oui down braquage finale vendredi 30
avril à 21h seulement sur canal+
l'enfant du pays brise d'exxon nous
vient tout droit de jaude a accompagné
d'une star de cinéma à l'eau madison
j'étais trouver un autre rôle un petit
rôle mais c'est quoi ce rôle c'est pas
enfin c'est plutôt comme un genre même
réunion ce sera purement professionnel
c'est moi comme je ne suis pas d'accord
je dois quitter la ville et toute façon
je t'envoie toutes les confirmations de
désinvolture pour parer nuit en enfer
des lèvres et jeté un sérieux
donc ça c'est ce qui advient ouais elle
est géniale
bryce milson parce que tu veux te dans
notre petite ville bienvenue à la maison
[Musique]
ora
oui les amis je suis heureux je suis
vraiment design
j'ai loué un jet ce matin juste pour
venir te voir je vais te reconquérir ma
belle super
si toutes ces personnes sont tes amis
pourquoi ne pas leur dire la vérité qu
on n'est pas ensemble
le coeur a ses raisons que la raison
ignore
je fais une erreur c'est pour cette
raison que les agents ne sortent pas
avec leurs clients et moi je n'ai pas
mon mot à dire je sais qu on fait juste
semblant
pourtant quand on est tous les deux je
me sens bien
cette photo que vous dites à régir les
régions quoi
[Musique]
m ca
tu es certaine qu'on n'est pas en train
de faire une on doit pas toujours ceux
pillon règle
[Musique]